like this altitude I can run flat out
for a half mile before my hands shake
this episode is brought to you by
headspace more than 80% of the people I
have interviewed world-class performers
across the military entertainment sports
and beyond all have some type of
meditative practice I tried for years
and years and failed miserably the key
is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than 4 million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is rooted in thousands of years of
tradition supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder Andy pettite combs TED talk
which has more than 5.5 million views
his last name is PUD di Co MBE if you
want to look that up but otherwise
download the free headspace app I have
it on my phone and begin there take ten
program for ten days of guided
meditation completely free ten minutes a
day that's all it takes you should give
it a shot
headspace calm forward-slash Tim just go
to headspace calm forward-slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business current thumbnail
or any other design I recommend checking
out 99 designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I use them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one New York Times bestseller
I've also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs dot-com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free $99 upgrade on your first design so
check it out 99 designs com forward
slash Tim
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show or it is usually my job
to deconstruct world-class performers
across all different areas and
industries whether they be military
chess sports entertainment or otherwise
business of course the obvious one this
time it is a conversation between
friends and I am extremely excited to
have Kevin Kelly back on the show Kevin
Kelley I've said this before might be
the real-life most interesting man in
the world I'm not making up what I'm
about to read to you
he is senior maverick at Wired magazine
which he co-founded in 1993 he also
co-founded the all species Foundation a
nonprofit aimed at cataloging and
identifying every living species on
earth in his spare time of course I'm
using that tongue-in-cheek
he writes best-selling books many of
them co-founded the Rosetta project
which is building an archive of all
documented human languages and serves on
the board of the long now foundation as
part of the last he's investigating how
to revive and restore endangered or
extinct species including the woolly
mammoth that has not made up folks we
touched on a lot of really fun stuff in
this episode and when Kevin arrived at
my house to record I had certain plans
and I asked him what he wanted to
highlight or focus on and we just
decided to catch up as friends so this
is very truly the type of conversation
that led me in the first place many
moons ago to ask why don't I record
these and share these conversations
because I have so much fun catching up
with friends like Kevin and this is
about as close to yeah
a banter over drinks as you're going to
get in my life certainly putting this
out publicly so I hope you enjoy it we
touch on all sorts of things
stories about Jeff Bezos and his email
management approach favorite books
impactful books tech literacy why there
are quote novi are experts and quote
which is very inspiring and there is a
video that didn't make it into this
interview but Kevin mentioned afterward
that I think is the history of Japan in
nine minutes
that I highly recommend everybody check
out we talked about the evolution of
China why he spent so much time in China
artificial intelligence network effects
virtual reality GMO we talked about
everything and if you think I am the
only big fan of Kevin well of course
that's not true
here is a little bit of praise for his
most recent book called the inevitable
and these are real quotes and I'll just
I'll truncate some of them so here we go
quote anyone can claim to be a prophet a
fortune teller or a futurist and plenty
of people do what makes Kevin Kelly
different is that he's right and it goes
on and on that's David Pogue many of you
will know then we have quote Kevin Kelly
has been predicting our technological
future with uncanny prescience for years
now he gives us a glimpse of how the
next three decades will unfold that's
earnest client author ready player one
and then also referring to the book the
inevitable that is Marc Andreessen who I
have in the podcast recently co-founder
of in recent Horowitz technological icon
refers to it as an automatic must read
so I hope you enjoyed this very informal
and wide-ranging conversation with none
other than Kevin Kelley and if you want
to listen to a longer conversation where
I dig into his bio and learn all sorts
of nuggets that even I didn't know then
you can check out 4-hour work week comm
forward slash Kevin just got a four hour
work week on forward slash Kevin you can
find previous conversations with him
enjoy
Kevin welcome back to the show it's
always a pleasure Tim it's so great to
be here
fantastic low horizontal space thank you
yeah it's great do you have you in in my
house for a change I remember still the
very first quantified self meet up at
your place in Pacifica with however many
people who were there was like 20 25
people that showed up with a call too if
you think you're quantifying yourself
come and then was one of the people who
arrived it was a broad spectrum of folks
it was it was really here we had no idea
what to expect this is Gary wolf and I
probably eight or nine years ago and
that was the very first meeting of the
quantified self movement and it was
meeting in my studio in Pacifica and
where is quantified self now what is the
scope of that yeah there's like meetings
in almost 300 cities around the world
and we have international conference
once a year so it's entered into
vocabulary I mean that is people talk
about it whether for or against it there
are course tons and tons of hardware
sensors the last CES before this year
was called the quantified self CES
because there are so many wearables the
Apple watch being one of many so it's
sort of entered into the mainstream in a
certain sense it remains to be seen
where it goes next like you know you're
probably not wearing your Fitbit today
and so people have spells with this
where they find it useful and the
question is how deep can these sensors
go so that they're kind of something
that everybody does it's a new normal I
think we're still a ways from that I
don't think we're that far away from it
being opt out though instead of opt in
right and for most people actually
you're already quantifying yourself
because you have an iPhone with an
accelerometer that has location tracking
and so on the the fascination that I
have with your life extends in many
different directions but one is there's
the Kevin Kelly futurist technologist
and then there's the Kevin Kelly and
they're one in the same of course but
the the other another aspect of you
sends me your family letters and I love
getting these letters they've read like
fiction quite frankly I mean it's it's
straight out of like Rin Tin Tin and I
remember just recently getting a text
from you and it was from a number I
didn't recognize and what what did it
say I just finished tracking elephants
temple procession elephants in Kerala
I'm on my way to Oman like tomorrow
whatever yeah would you like to come and
I was like and the you spend time with
the Amish we've talked about this in
episodes in the first episode we did
together certainly but at the same time
we can get really granular and tactical
but first before we go to I have a
question about email and books and a
Hamilton and so on uh why do you spend
so much time in China and you've you've
written a little bit about this in your
family letter updates yeah yeah but you
seem to spend every year more and more
time in China so and why do they love
you so much yes okay so there's a very
complicated reason my connection to
China is is kind of deep starting with
the fact that my wife is Chinese so so
and my kids are all bilingual and have
spent time in China but more importantly
I wrote a book called out-of-control 25
years ago or maybe more now 1994 I guess
and it was a little early because it was
about how the internet was going to
happen before the internet really
happened it was about how this
decentralized sharing things were going
to that were kind of almost biologically
inspired and they were gonna go into our
built environment and I what I was
talking about and I was talking about
all the rules of the internet were gonna
run by before there was an Internet and
it kind of never really took off in the
US but it was translated into Chinese
crowdsource translated about five years
ago
and it was just at the right time when
Ponemah Jack Ma and all these guys in
China were starting their internet
companies and they read the book in
Chinese and were influenced by it and
talked about it and there's kind of a
little bit of a her social herb
in China and so when these famous
successes were talking about this book I
don't think we do that at all exactly
right
everybody started to buy it and so I
became for better or worse kind of the
Alvin Toffler of China and they have
this ridiculous idea that I'm predicting
the future and because in fact there was
very little predictions in the book it
was just that I was talking about things
that later on became common so they have
this idea they're always introduced me
as the guy who invented the internet or
and who predicted the internet and of
course the next person who introduces me
have to has to kind of wrap that up it's
embarrassing at this point but I have I
have a lot of fans in China who are
trying really hard to be innovative and
and and and they're kind of listening to
people from the West not just me about
how to do that in their culture and so
my book has become one of those books
that they're reading to understand where
it's going because they are rushing into
that future so fast that they really
need all the guidance they can get for
people who don't know Toffler can you
yeah give a little of context so Alvin
Toffler wrote a book called future shock
in the 70s or 80s I don't remember where
it was but he is in some ways for a long
time was the most famous futurist and
even people who didn't know what he was
talking about knew them as a futurist so
he was sort of like if you had heard
that if he knew about a futurist was
Alvin Toffler even though you hadn't
read his book and I have the same thing
in China where people might recognize my
name and call me a futurist even though
they have never read anything by him so
Alvin Toffler his book the future shock
is still worth reading he was the one
who introduced the term future shock
which was that people would actually
have a that there were kind of like a
resistance or a reaction to the future
in general just because things were
changing fast
but he also invented in that same book
or the next one the idea the term
prosumer which is the person who is both
producing and consuming which we now
call kind of user-generated content but
this idea that most of this economy
would be prosumers that was his idea in
like the 70s or 80s he was late it has
incredible yeah how do you see China
changing in the next say 10 to 20 years
I believe that China is within 5 years
on the cusp of actually having a global
brand that of something that everybody
in the world would want meaning the Nike
a not only blank yeah exactly whether
it's a car or a drone or a camera or
some some appliance or a device or a
digital thing that would be world-class
in its innovation in its quality and
like like Sony became eventually for the
Japanese and the reason why I think
that's because as you said I go there a
lot I'm going there probably every three
months and then I'm I'm not just going
to the big cities which I do my talks at
but I always will take an extra week or
two and go into the hinterlands out to
you know you nan or quan chi or some
other province and I spent some time on
the Silk Road way in the West where it's
Muslim to get a sense of the other China
and the to gauge the depth of their
dream now I'm kind of like what did the
Chinese want the going so fast where are
they aiming for and what they are trying
to do is is innovate and they're coming
to the west to learn how to innovate and
I think like to like we talked to
Japanese how to do quality you know the
Japanese says how do we do quality so
they went to tailor and all these guys
gave them a list if do this and do this
and do this and you'll have quality the
Japanese went through the list they did
it and then they became kind of the
world's expert on making quality Chinese
are saying how do we do innovation and
all the people from the West myself well
you need to have you know garage you
didn't have some science fairs you've
got to have you know innovation hubs
you've got to had startups you have to
have all this stuff and so they're
following they're going down the
checklist and they're going to we're
going to do the
we're gonna do that we're gonna do that
and I think they will they are doing it
and they are going to succeed in making
something that we all want and I don't
know what it is but I feel that they're
they're really kind of doing all the
things that they want to do although
there's two cultural characters that
they haven't yet gotten to and those two
cultural ones it's they haven't yet
embraced failure and they still don't
collectively question authority enough
and they're working on those and they
know that they have to do those and they
know they're difficult to do
collectively I mean individually of
course there's no problem the Chinese
come to America they can do all those
but collectively as a culture
those are challenging for them they're
working on them you know it'll be some
more years but I think they will do it
yes if you look at let's say Singapore I
know we're getting pretty China focused
here but just as a sidebar you were
talking about visiting these sort of
far-flung right right corners of China
China is just for those people listening
who haven't been is a lot more diverse
than you might think
and in fact when you hear Chinese the
language for instance like Mandarin
Chinese it's basically Beijing dialect
Chinese and then on top of that if you
were to go to China I mean they're many
ways to say Chinese depending on where
you are and it indicates a lot of how
you feel so you could say like drum gua
or actually exact center like the center
country Middle Kingdom language right
then you can also say like Han you know
so the hot the language of the Han
people right right who are the dominant
ethnic group
well you if you go to Taiwan now the
mainlanders hate that but if you say boy
that means kind of like the the mainland
talk I mean it's I'm translating very
liberally here and that of course really
irks the Chinese who view Taiwan is sort
of a rogue province that is nonetheless
still a part of them much like a kind of
Quebec or something in Canada but the
the other point that I was going to make
is is our question rather that's going
to pose is if you look at say Singapore
so Singapore is has
with some success for at least I would
say the last 10 years to replicate
Silicon Valley and they've faced very
similar cultural hurdles but they have
fantastic at least my impression is
financial resources they have unilateral
freedom to kind of do whatever they want
and they have a well-educated population
they are very very very small right the
the the sandbox is incredibly small you
can walk around Singapore in a day and
then you're like what am I gonna do here
I need to go to Malaysia like have a new
meal why will China differ is it just
the sheer number of people that they
have to choose from or to filter from
from which you can find like the Michael
Jordan's the Jeff Bezos the fill in the
blank absolutely I think I think this is
a with retic problem I mean one point
four billion people by the way there's
like you know 0.3 billion
North Americans this is like there's a
billion more of them I think there
definitely is a critical mass a scale
that the that the Chinese have and it
kind of it's almost kind of translated
into a momentum that you need and then
that you have this critical mass of
people behind you doing and they gave
that kind of you were mentioning the
adversity which Singapore does not have
as much F but did have a lot for being a
little city but not compared to China
you have a huge diversity in China you
say not just the language but even
ethnically geographically and so I think
they have all those necessary
requirements that the requisite
complexity that you would need to make
something but there were I would say two
things one is if they attempt to make
another Silicon Valley I think that
fails their network effects in all these
things and the network effect says that
the best get bigger and the bigger you
get the better you get the better you
get the bigger again so you have this
sort of compounding acceleration and
that means that there's only going to be
one or two dominant players and by the
way AI is going to be a network effects
phenomena social media is a network
effect phenomenon and the kind of
startup culture is a network effect
phenomena in a particular category so if
they try to do is Silicon value for
software it
not happen if they decide to take
something which I think they might like
robotics or aviation or biotech and
really develop and grow to sufficient
scale I think they could have a an
equivalent and right now they do have
one in manufacturing the right Pearl
River Delta Area from Guangzhou to
Shenzhen Hong Kong I mean that is that's
basically one they do the world's best
manufacturing in China it's not because
it's the cheapest it's because it's the
best and they have this whole ecosystem
with thousands and thousands of
suppliers and dynamic real-time you know
inventory control and his whole thing
and so they are now they do have the
Silicon Valley for manufacturing in that
area and they will continue to grow that
and people are going there not because
there are the cheapest in some cases
they aren't but because they have the
absolute best in manufacturing how much
of the and this is I for those people
listening Kevin and I decided to wing it
we had up we had a conversation prior to
recording and this is just us talking
about stuff that we're interested in so
I've been over the last few weeks
discussing with folks visiting Silicon
Valley and the origins of Silicon Valley
we're trying my best to explain why
Silicon Valley may have happened here
and not elsewhere how much of Silicon
Valley do you think can be attributed to
a handful of companies that just
happened to land here like Fairchild or
some of these semiconductor companies
the inability to enforce a non-compete
contracts in California which I think
you know allowed these people to then
split off and form many other companies
then it might have stepped on their
former bosses territory or other like
how do you when somebody asks you why
did Silicon Valley happen here what do
you say so there were reasons why there
was actually a really good book on this
by Annalise axel in I believe her name
was and she studied route 128 around
Boston and Silicon Valley and compared
it to because Route 28 actually had a
little head start in this kind of tech
world and why did didn't they
become the Silicon Valley why did why
did Sand Hill Road Yellin and and part
of the reasons there's a number of
different reasons but one of them was
because I think you mentioned a couple
but there's others and that was Silicon
Valley was so far from the west coast
government the DC government that they
each government used to be the East
Coast government DC that they had to
find a whole bunch of different sources
for funding and they kind of they
invented the funding model which 1:28
around Boston was still locked into a
lot of the government defense contracts
right okay and so that was a kind of a
difficulty but a liberation for Silicon
Valley where there was kind of really
divorced from the government handouts or
now we could government subsidies the
government funding not completely but
enough to actually really develop this
other alternative way of financing
things venture capital right venture
capital and so and and I think
psychologically there was other this
other division this other kind of
divorcing from you know the whole
California story of no adult supervision
not asking for permission which started
in 49ers and before I think that also
continued to influence the culture so
there was a there was a cultural
innovation and many people say that you
know the the greatest invention from
Silicon Valley was not the transistor or
software it was this model it was this
innovation model that is the kind of
meta the innovation model meaning the
set of beliefs and Maxim's and so on
that those people carried in their head
exactly right the the the the venture
funding model the startup model this
this method this culture that would
reward you know the joke was was you
know you change a job and you walk
across the street it was like and and
also the fact that you would encourage
to change your job no life I mean far
from life along employment but this idea
that know you've been here a couple
years time to move on and so there's a
whole bunch of things that are
ingredients to that and this book study
this in a kind of a more economically
rigorous way of why did one so
Pass together remember fascinating
documentaries on this as well and maybe
it's all sort of hindsight logical but
in reality 90% of it was just random
collision of people and factors I don't
know I would also recommend John Mark
Hoffs book with this really trippy title
called what the Dormouse said what the
Dormouse said said which is about the
hippie origins of the personal computer
industry so there's a whole nother
strand which is very influential which
was the fact that the hippie generation
embraced computers unlike the other
technologies that they were rejected and
they embrace them as from Doug Engelbart
to Steve Jobs to allow the AI guys and a
lot of people in the early computer
industry had kind of a little the hippie
background and they saw these things as
augmentations as it basically is kind of
like a new-age way to augment the human
and so there was you know when the
people left the communes they tried the
communes they didn't work without long
hair but they learned a lot of skills
including small business skills making
their candles and their sandals and
there you know macrame selling you know
honey or whatever was so unlike people
who went to college and never dropped
out who went to work for the big
organizations the IBM they were at the
craft fairs yeah getting business skills
then when they came along as they
transferred those directly into this
idea of smaller businesses which were
not cool in the mean small business if
you told somebody in active 50s that you
were at a start-up that was a code for
like I'm unemployed I was fired
it's like consultant right analog
have you ever been to I know jumping
around here but to Kristiania in yes in
Copenhagen Copenhagen so there's this
area for people who haven't been
called Kristiania I'm pretty sure I'm
getting it roughly right and it's
effectively like an hippie slash
anarchist communism Idul of or around
Copenhagen and there are gates that you
walk through and it says here ends the
european union right when you walk
through and and as you described it's
like people riding like walking their
kids around in wheelbarrows making honey
making candles they have breweries is
such a funky experience so autonomous
region we start off with kind of a
squatter city that that is now semi
legal and some some capacity and they do
have their own little government at this
point
and they're there and it's quite
extensive I mean you could spend it's
not quite as big as Singapore and it's a
worth so we're the experiment to go
visit because there are lots of
alternative governments and structures
and cultures are really important and
let me just say one thing about travel
before we kind of go on to other things
I travel a lot not just to China but to
other places as much as I can because I
find that it really keeps my mind
flexible in fact I find it that it's the
most exercise I can do in a short amount
of time than anything else I mean sure I
can learn a new language to do these
other things but I finally could do all
those while you're travelling to but
travel really forces me to be flexible
and to confront others and to think
about things differently and even
whether if I have a different an idea
there
it's just that habit of trying to think
and come at things differently that if
I'm really really useful in addition to
the fact that you you actually literally
are looking at your own culture from a
different lens but even just the general
habit of trying to let go of what you
think you know and I go to China above
all else because every time I go I
actually have decided I learn I know
less than the last time I mean there's
so much happening there it's happening
so fast it's so big the Chinese have no
idea what's happening and I think I know
something and then I go and I realize I
don't know what's happening here either
I know less than that last time I
visited
or it's a different country right
exactly in the last time here right and
so I so III think travel is so important
particularly to young people that I
really believe that should be subsidized
by at the federal level yeah I think gap
I think gap years should be managed I
think I think a two-year national
service should be a requirement and you
can fulfill in any way you want
including going overseas and working at
the Peace Corps or something visa
whatever it is take two years you want
to go to military fine you want to go to
inner-city find you want to go overseas
find will pay for two years
nothing would transform America that's
having a overseas experience for the
majority of people who by the way don't
have passports at this moment I agree
could not agree more and we we agreed on
a few other things earlier when we were
talking about podcast questions and I
was making some funky mushroom coffee
not of the psychedelic sort that I'll
describe some other time but you
suggested that I ask people about their
email systems how do they handle inbound
email right because because foreign
ordinary people they get a lot of email
but if you have any level of success or
notoriety or prominence dealing with the
incoming in a sane way that is actually
works as is a real mystery to me so
people like yourselves or even to the
other people who get a lot of demands on
them how do you actually deal with email
do you have more than one account if you
have more than one account how you
handle it do you have your assistant
involved etc etc there are many
different things right and you mentioned
you had a conversation of the Jeff basis
and I said we have to save that podcast
so now I have to ask what was this
conversation so I I had the opportunity
to ask Jeff at some point about his
email because I you know what it's like
who do I send it to how do you do your
email he says well I have and this again
I think this is a probably a 10 year old
answer so I can't verify this is
happening but I finally figured out what
to do and so here's what it is is
anything you sent to me and his actual
emails fairly well circulated he says
anything you sent him
my assistant will read and they are my
assistants plural will read and they are
in charge of responding or doing
something with it right vetting whatever
whoever the appropriate with note to
give the appropriate response and but I
also read it all and since I don't
really normally answer it unless you
know there's something it's it and then
if there is something that I want to
respond to I'll respond to so the worst
case scenario is that you get two
replies for me from my assistant if it
needs to be replied to and me so in
other words he sends everything so
everything goes through in a parallel
circuit once to his assistants and they
deal with hasp what has to be and most
of its probably couldn't be ignored
those that the need to be done something
they may not shim or whatever and he's
also looking at it and he can reply
personally to it and he said the worst
is you might get two and so that that
seems to be I mean you know he has one
email and I have gotten responses to
that email and sometimes it just kind of
goes and obviously he doesn't do respond
to it into the ether right do you still
have exists this is something that I've
had to get increasingly better at
because the the tools and tactics as I
laid them out for instance in the 4-hour
workweek still work very well however
I've had to develop sort of more nuanced
layers on top of what I did because now
it's thousands of email right coming and
hitting write me my assistants every one
and deciding how to vet and use tools
like boomerang to schedule things to be
set in the future or automatic
follow-ups you name it moving a lot of
internal communication to slack so that
it's separate from the inbox that are do
you still have an assistant and a
separate researcher I do I have an
assistant and a full-time researcher but
they don't we they don't do my mail so I
do all my own mail what does your
researcher currently helping you with if
you can talk about it yeah I would love
to talk about it in fact we just had a
review today so I've been working on a
project a review meaning that you have
an annual review of an annual review
with the two people work for
so once a year we sit down and we you
know do employee review we talked about
the past year and we evaluate what's
coming up and so what her name is
Camille and what Camille is working on
is we are gathering every long-term
forecast that we can find anywhere in
any of the industries or published
anywhere we were bringing them together
and and we're gonna try to integrate all
the long-term forecasts into kind of one
integrated forecast of the future launch
hour meaning 10 years or more so
forecasts could be anything from this is
how we see gasoline prices moving in the
next 20 years to this is how we
anticipate air travel to MU the number
of seats filled and air travel to move
in the next right years and we're going
even brought Oh like the future of
sports and number of attendees at sports
games and you know transportation going
through the whole list of things so
she's been working on it for six months
and we probably have another six months
of what is what I call the official
future haven't been trained in gbn which
was a consultancy that did strategy for
global companies the the mantra was that
all predictions are wrong and generally
particularly official futures so there's
official extrapolation you kind of take
what's been happening for the past five
years and you extrapolate they are
enviably not correct because they don't
because things jag and jag and new
things you know are invented that kind
of disrupt the the pattern but my
premise is that while they're wrong that
they're still useful and if they would
be particularly useful if they were
integrated together so you would say
well here's the you know the future of
Transportation looks like this in the
future of you know electric cars looks
like this and these bus can't be right
we have to kind of they have to come
inform each other in some ways so that's
the next step of kind of integrating and
have these official futures inform each
other and to see if I
make a scenario that's more useful out
of the sum of the parts so she has been
working on that for six months and she
also did the research when I was doing
the big cover story for Wired on VR so
for five months I was trying out every
single VR headset input content that I
could and I wrote this article in the
way wired works like other magazines is
they have this fact-checking which is
sort of some ways kind of a legal is a
cover-your-ass thing which means every
single statement that I make has to be
there verified and proven it's like a
scholarly article like a footnote which
is like totally insane but that's what
you have to do so they're involved in
like you know I you say something that
seems obvious to you you know there's I
don't know some statement VR is we you
know people get sick in it or they have
motion sickness can you prove where does
that come from well how do you know
about that and so these things so she
was did a lot of the hard leg work in
finding the documentation for these
kinds of statements that aren't
footnoted in the article but actually
are footnoted and when i turn over to
them so i have a completely scholarly
footnoted article people don't realize
that but behind the scenes of New Yorker
and Wired and places like that there is
a huge amount of there's a full-time
staff that will fact check every single
fact oh yeah it's a big dedicated staff
by the way books do not do that and
newspapers do not do that yeah it's we
spend a lot of time talking about all of
that so going back to my assistants so I
have a researcher who does all that kind
of research and anything else I need
research on which I mean that's the main
thing but there's this was my one dream
was to have somebody and this was you
know kind of even before Google that I
could ask you know would I do a lot of
travel and so they sometimes do research
on simple things like is it okay
is it a saying idea to rent a car
oh man or should I get a driver hmm you
know it's like so you kind of troll the
the TripAdvisor boards or lonely this
department it's just kind of looking
around yeah so there's that kind of
stuff how do you decide aside from those
types of logistics how do you how do you
choose projects for your your researcher
to help you with and you could delve
into anything that you'd like so how do
you choose
I mean projects in general what am I
going to do next
sure yeah how do you choose where you're
gonna do next okay so this this has
taken me a long time to get there but
what I one of the questions that I will
you know there's you've seen these Venn
diagrams of things that you like to do
they need to other people need yeah but
for me there's actually a third
important circle and that's not just
like things that I want to do is so that
there has to be a key thing that you
know that I'm good at doing that's the
second thing because there's lots of
things I could have would have fun doing
but I see I'm no good at but so they
have to be good I'm good at and then
there's kind of like you maybe would be
useful to other people but the this
other circle that's become more
important to me is can anybody else do
it
yeah right if somebody else can do it I
am NOT going to do it
and I spend a lot of time trying to give
away ideas and trying to talk about what
I'm doing in the hope that someone else
comes along and says oh I'm doing that
and that's like oh what a relief good
though I'm not gonna do that I'm talking
about this future stuff if I can find
out someone else out there and they
write to me in there say I'm doing there
I was like oh my gosh thank you now I
don't have to do that because and so
when I'm trying to when I'm trying to
look for is really good things that I
would enjoy other people value that
nobody else is going to do they can't
convince anyone else to do they think
it's a terrible idea I think it's a
lousy idea but for some reason I think
this is a good idea and I can't get
anyone else to do it I can't talk no one
will steal it from me you're trying to
give it away take it it's like I have to
do that now but
so I get asked well why don't you write
a book on this when you write a book on
that and I'm like they're already plenty
of good books on both of those right and
it has to be something that bothers me
for so long it seems like such a
crackpot idea everybody else I can't buy
it anywhere to scratch the itch and I'm
like okay well that's that's me just
just like fix that neuroses you know
that neuroses I have to address it so
the title titles are important and you
mentioned the title of a book just a few
minutes ago before we started recording
the caught my attention because we were
looking at the slow creep of books and
piles on my my table which is is
ironically right next to this Marie
Kondo book on the met the Japanese magic
of cleaning up I can never remember the
name of that be more accurate the book
about cleaning up is on a stack of other
stuff exactly which I took a photograph
of because it's a lot better than it was
it used to be kind of like the trash
compactor and Star Wars and this and
this this book on Japanese declaring or
just kind of surf this like wave of
float some Jets some around my house
it's a lot better now but you you
mentioned that another book called all
too much all too much and who actually
preceded her book at least in English
and I thought it was so valuable that it
in this really huge book I did called
cool tools I listed it as the very first
tool which was how to deal with all this
stuff
how not to have a bunch of stuff and I
actually found I gave it a whole page
because I thought the message worth was
so profound because it's not about like
tidying up and cleaning he it's it's he
talks about the fact that if you have
something that is valuable you need to
show it hiding things if you're if
you're if you have collections and
you're and they're not visible then
they're not working for you so it's not
against collecting things but if you're
collecting they have to be prominent
they have to bring you joy they have to
be doing something in your life and that
what you want was decluttering this
basically to remove the junk so you have
room for your treasure and all these
kinds of things words it's not about the
stuff it's about your mental state your
openness to new ideas and
the clutter is in some ways prohibiting
your self-fulfillment you're the best
you because it's hiding your you're
buried under it and so there is this
sort of I wouldn't call pop psychology
but it's a it is a little bit about
trying to get it to the core of what you
were about what your house is about what
your life is about and making room for
these things and the kinds of techniques
that he uses are very similar to what
the Japanese gal I can't remember her
name unknown kind of which is you know
you pick up something and does that does
that object give you joy actually what
she does is differently she says take
everything in your house and she goes my
categories put it all your clothes in
the center make a big pile and by
default all your gonna get rid of all of
them and at but as you're going through
if you pick up something that gives you
joy that that's what you keep everything
else is is gone and the same thing about
all your other possessions
you know category by category you decide
they're all by default going to be gone
and you only retrieve those things that
when you that gives you joy and that's a
little bit what he's talking about in
that same kind of profound way I feel
like that I tried I did try this I give
it a good college try and I did find
certain aspects of it very helpful but
then the joy part I picked up everywhere
like these printouts that were like
legal documents or tax returns and I'm
like not joyful this is not giving me
joy but it would be very neglectful and
bit responsible to me to throw these out
now what Marie Kondo the topic of
simplicity is one that I try to
consistently return to because our lives
tend to entropy right right what books
or resources have you found helpful for
simplifying your life and if that's not
the right question you can tackle it a
different way well I think it's all too
much this kind of decluttering and in
her book are actually helpful in
simplifying things um I and maybe not as
a big fan of simplicity as you are I
think our lives are inherently more
complex than our parents and our
grandparents and our children and their
grandchildren and future generations
will be more accomplished
I think that is generally the drift of
this thing we call life and evolution in
technology is and they're going to
become more and more complicated and I
think you know right now people are some
people are very upset of our kind of
distracted manner or the the way that we
kind of skip through or surf through the
nets and the internet and social media I
actually think that's a very sane
response to the environment where we we
are kind of we have to scan because
things are much more complicated and
we'll do more scanning in the future so
I I think there may be there is kind of
like appropriate kinds of complexity you
know complications
maybe we avoid and complexity is is okay
I mean the thing about life is that it's
surfs a very fine line between rigid
order which is death and complete chaos
and there is this sort of there is this
edge of chaos they call it this edge
where there's this sort of a particular
kind of falling forward or particular
kind of chaotic order or orderly chaos
or something and I think so it's not
rigid simplicity and it's not this
overly chaotic complications there is a
there is a very fine
a variety of complexity that is not just
healthy but it is the source and the
genius of I think health wealth and
everything else that we want so I think
that I might be able to ask a better
question which is in face of the
notifications and social media pings
and so on and so forth a lot of people
feel anxious right and they feel
conflicted and overcommitted right maybe
you just mask it really well but I've
never had that feeling from you I've
never gotten the impression that you
feel those things why why not yeah and I
mean are there particular rules or ways
that you I there is one thing
and that is and maybe this is kind of a
Zen thing you know the Zen mantra is
sit sit walk walk don't wobble I haven't
heard that before yeah so this is idea
that okay when I'm with a person that's
total priority anything else is
multitasking no no no no it's just like
so I have a priority you know the
people-to-people person person it
Trump's anything else and if there's
something else going on you know
whatever
I have given my dedication to this if I
go to a play or a movie I am at the
movie I'm not anywhere else it's like a
hundred percent I'm going to listen if I
go to a conference it's like I'm gonna
go to the conference that's true I've
been I've never seen you on a device
while with or near other people right
now that I think about it and even that
wired before I had a head of rules like
of the fun but with a person person in
the phone rings no never if I'm on the
phone and the notification rings no I'm
on the phone and so I I think this sense
of and you can kind of have her priority
if you want whatever it is but it's sort
of like I'm gonna give I'm gonna be
present whatever that is at that time
and everything else is sort of we'll
deal with it later
sit sit walk walk don't wobble right
what books have you found have given you
and I always come back to books doesn't
have to be books sources something that
people listening could yeah look at
themselves we listen to have given you
rules like that or Maxim's or sayings
that have proved very useful well you
know I come from religious tradition and
I actually think some of the religious
test texts are very good for that and I
think it's very hard to kind of read the
Bible all the way through by the way I
recommend that you do that at least once
in your life no matter who you are sit
down well it takes a long time but read
through the Bible read a modern version
it'll take you some time it is the
probably the most amazing things you
haven't read yet it's highly disturbing
highly influential and whatever your
opinion about it is it's you're gonna be
wrong whatever you think you know
whether you think it's the greatest I
mean read it through it's an amazing
book and I say the same thing about the
Quran
try to read you know the the Sufi stuff
there's nothing that I enjoy more than
at night reading Rumi yeah I mean it's
just something about it just he is a
Sufi mystic from Afghanistan who is a
transcendent thought leader made me like
Seneca or something he has tremendous
wisdom and so I think the wisdom of the
Ancients in general have a lot to to
offer us and I think you know the
reading the Zen parables you know sound
of one hand clapping zan mine beginner
Minds these kinds of things for me that
kind of wisdom it's not like you have to
be slavish obedient to them take what
you find useful move on but I found a
lot of use in in in those texts so we
have in a sense these timeless
philosophies and belief structures that
can help us make better decisions and so
on then we have subject matter expertise
of different types right that can become
more or less relevant over time and we
were chatting before we started
recording about a question that I get
asked all the time which is what
industries should I be paying attention
to in the next three to five years what
skills should I learn and most of these
are business focused but what skills
should I learn to be able to take
advantage of new non-obvious industries
in the next year right and you mentioned
and I might be getting the wording here
off but sort of tech literacy or techno
literacy techno literacy different types
of living right you elaborate on that
right so so let me put again a little
bit of contents context I would really
I'll talk a little bit more but let me
just preface and say that I do talk a
bit about this in my new book called the
inevitable which is I'm one of the few
copies tim has one of the first copies
are off the press and it's talking about
the next 20 to 30 years mostly about
digital technology and the trends that I
consider non-negotiable inevitable in a
sense of there's not much we can do
about it there's a lot we can do about
this specific
but not about the bigger trends they are
coming whether we want to in the
subtitle so the inevitable subtitle
understanding the 12 technological
forces that will share our future and
one of the first chapters talks about
this question of skills I think that the
specifics like what language should I be
learning in school or what business
skills should I have I think what I
would think are more useful and what I
counsel even my own kids about there are
these kind of mental level skills the
skills of learning how to learn the
skills of learning how technology in
general learns or operates which is what
I would call the Tecna literacy skills
and so an example of a technology skill
is that the cost
besides the initial purchase cost of a
technology whatever technology you buy
you now have a maintenance cost that
maintenance cost is like making sure
that is upgraded or integrated or just
maintaining it in some capacity so
there's there's several levels of the
cost it's not just how much does it cost
to buy but how much does it cost to
maintain in your life how there's
there's a price to dealing with it when
it breaks down upgrading that there is
certain like owning a boat a little bit
you know it's like not the initial cost
of the boat it's the maintenance that
really is the costly part and the same
thing with anything that we buy so if
you get something into your house
there's now a relationship with that
thing you it's like having a pet or an
animal or something you have to deal
with it and it's interaction with other
things that's just a kind of an
elementary thing there's there's a sense
in which there's also negative costs too
in terms of whatever it is that we have
there's going to be some downside and
journalists are usually pretty good
about kind of identifying you should pay
attention to what people say about the
negative aspects of it because they are
real it's not that they should
discourage you from using the technology
and I not argue that it shouldn't but we
should be aware of them and and willing
a certain sets to pay the price what
would be an example a clear example to
you of a technology with a downside that
perhaps is under appreciate or downsides
that are underappreciated automobiles
kill 1 million humans on her
earth every year now if magic if we were
gonna need to introduce automobiles and
say here's here we get cars don't kill 1
million of us do you want to drive it
not the best pitch I've heard I'm saying
there are all these hidden there's and
but but that's real and this is one of
the reasons why I think driverless cars
are going to even though they will I
mean so here's the thing the first
person the first car of driverless car
that kills a person people will go
completely bananas but we're killing 1
million of them ourselves and there and
so that's not registered for some reason
it's like that doesn't count they've
lost the reference point right exactly
and so um so so there is gonna be the I
mean driverless cars will kill some
people but they're not going to kill as
many as we kill and so in an evaluating
that and evaluating whether you want to
get in and there's there gonna be by the
way ethical issues with driverless cars
because we give ourselves a pass when we
have an accidents like oh I I didn't
have time we react and it wasn't
thinking
but the driverless car has to be
programmed and so you have to give it a
preference if it's if there's an
accident - you give the passenger safety
preference over the pedestrian right or
do you and give the three elementary
school kids it's not a problem
exactly right let the trolley problem
but the thing is is that when you're
like 7 or 7 years old right and so when
you go to buy a car and Volvo says hey
we give passengers preference is the
programming right one of the selling
points percent less likely to be
sacrificed exactly in compromising
environments so I think there's I think
there are and so technology is like say
we need to be cognizant of this that
there's cost if there's ethical
dimensions to this that and and there's
there other technologies skills like the
fact that you don't really want to learn
a language programming language you want
to learn how to learn a language because
you're going to have to relearn it later
on and you
understand that you know how that when
you buy something it's kind of
immediately obsolete right it's always
by definition and so one of the things I
recommend is like you want to buy things
like five minutes before you need it not
ever before there's no sense in kind of
hoarding this stuff because it's just
going to change just in time just in
time just in case exactly and so there
there aren't there aren't there are
thinks I think those kinds of skills are
going to be much more useful and I think
I might have said this before but when I
was at Wired and we were doing hiring
first of all I never looked at anybody's
educational background I looked at their
experience in the motto that I had in my
head was you hire for attitude and the
skills we'll we'll train we train for
skills I wasn't really hiring people for
a skill set per se it was more of their
attitude their their orientation their
techni literacy their their ability to
to learn and adapt that was far more
valuable than the particular skills they
had now that some level skills play into
it and that's true there is a certain
skill requirement but I think maybe as
important is is the these other levels
now it makes me think of this I think
it's a bit from Neil Gaiman's
commencement speech make good heart but
he says at some point he realized that
there's three important components if
you want to keep a job and it is get
along with people have people like you
deliver things on time be good at your
job and he said the good news is you
don't actually need all three of two out
of the three if you have two out of the
three they'll keep you around do things
on time have people like you or be
really really good it's like you only
need two to three well do things on time
ours is is is really great but in terms
of in terms of other people who are
self-starter like you if you don't have
a job if you're trying to do something
the equivalent of that is just do lots
of this do lots of it over and over and
over again and I can't emphasize how
important that doing it a lot is
because the only way to get through the
only way to find out what you're really
good at or what no one else could do
that is basically that's a lifelong
project that's just through a lot
against the wall you have to do a lot in
a lot and in sticks it's the more
failures you have the more successes
there's it's a really very clear ratio
that's linked and you you just have to
do a lot that's the only way you can
find out what you're good at cuz you
know how many college kids young people
coming out they say I don't have that
passion I don't know what I'm good at
the only way that I know to find out
your passion is to actually work to it
by trying lots of stuff and becoming you
know expert at something right well in a
way I mean this is might sound cliched
but you know instead of discovering
yourself you're creating yourself and so
these these kids are the kids sound like
just an old man but these these young
people who graduate from college and
then they want to sit down and like
journal for 10 minutes or taking a
multiple-choice test to figure out their
myers-briggs and have their kind of
assignment for passion and I'm like
that's not how this works
like you're not you're not an ice you're
not a block of ice that's being chipped
away to reveal the sculpture underneath
it's like you're actually just like a
small piece of clay and all the other
bits and pieces need to be added and
there is a kernel of it that is you but
you need to construct them the way you
do that is by doing these experiments
and we're trying XY and z and everything
else in between and it's I still feel
like I'm doing that and it's I'm still
doing that yeah I'm almost 65 I'm still
doing that and the people that I respect
the most and my circle are still doing
that they're still asking themselves at
70 years old what am I gonna do when I
grow up you know I mean basically it's
like and Who am I what am I here for and
should I be doing this and and that's
actually why they I respect them so much
is because they are still constructing
their life rather than say discovering
it or finding it there they're
constructing it I think it's really
wonderful metaphor you said you said a
while back when we were just putzing
around in my living room looking at the
living wall and whatnot you said
there are no VR experts right right so
so so one of the things because I saw I
wrote this big cover story on Larry
about VR and a couple years ago I wrote
about AI and by the way these are the
kinds of things that are in my book the
inevitable where I'm looking at these
things which are coming so AI is coming
in a big way VR is coming the
particulars of how it arrived who owns
it how its structured those are not
inevitable those aren't predictable and
we they make a lot of difference to us
so we have a lot of choice in this thing
but one of the things that one
emphasized is that right now basically
there are no VR experts it's it's
completely open we really we
collectively humans have no idea how VR
is gonna work what content will really
work best in VR what the necessary
amount of equipment will be what that
kind of consumer breakthrough version
will be and even though there is VR
today the VR today is good enough to
improve so it hasn't been good enough to
approve but now today with the oculus
and the vive and there's other stuff
it's now good enough to improve for a
reasons I could talk about and it will
improve very fast but there's no experts
and so that means that a person out
there listening to this could easily
become a VR expert okay
there's really no AI experts there are a
lot of people working on AI but but
compared to what we'll know in 20 years
from now we don't know anything and so
it's actually not that difficult to
become a an AI expert so let's say
someone listening said you know what
I've read about I've read about VR this
is really exciting
I'm tired of my comparative literature
major I'd like to switch gears and
really immerse myself right what would
you suggest they do if they seem to
earnest intelligent they're committed
they're like I want to become a VR
expert or AI you could pick your yeah
yeah so I mean there was a guy Kent by
who
runs the voices of ER podcast two years
ago he quit his job and he decided he
int his interviewed 400 is on 400
interviews of everyone was every person
working in VR
it's and that's his business his job now
is he's he just does interviews of the
voices of people working in VR he's kind
of doing the journalistic side I say
very very easy which is you purchase
some gear and you start making VR you
actually do it and it's you buy you'll
get a pair of google goggle goggle with
the cold Google VR the cardboard mm-hmm
but you can get for free and use your
phone and start making VR and you'll
learn more about it then then reading
about it then working whatever it is
trying to make trying to make a VR
experience duped by someone for five
minutes
the issues are incredible there's like
lighting issues there's continuity
issues there's we don't even have a
vocabulary for editing I mean for like
you know like in cinema we have a whole
syntax of what a cut is right huh you
know how do you do a jump and I just I
love x y&z we don't have any none of
that really works in VR doesn't mean the
same thing so yes something has to
invent all those the interface the the
mouse there's no mouse for VR I mean
there are people invent it but there's
nothing that has worked like the windows
and the mouse the angle Bart made so
there is so much that has to be invented
and that's somebody who just decides
that they're going to work at this every
day or every day on weekends or whatever
it is can make a huge advance and I
think you need to do it you know you'll
need to do it because you love it
because you know there's this is not
economics we're talking about right
investing into mastery it's having child
Marc Andreessen recently and he said
what did he say
I just had a complete mental blank lot
of very interesting things and you'll
remember and you will hear about them
another time because I just had a
complete slice that's gonna have to be a
footnote for later
what are you most excited about right
now I'm gonna take that kind of in the
professional sense of getting any sense
well and the personal sense I'm still
very excited by Asia Asia is a
combination for me of the future you
asked me before about I go to China to
hear what the future will be and also
because I have a love for the the Asian
traditions that are disappearing very
very fast and I'm trying to record them
so I go to Asia to photograph these
disappearing traditions ceremonies and
whatnot and she was just joking that I
just came back from Kerala India where I
was photographing these massive elephant
processions that the temples have with
40 elephants parading through and all
kinds of ceremonies that and I don't
know how long they can continue that
it's a very kind of expensive elaborate
spectacle and not just one place but
throughout the the rural areas and it's
like other areas that become modern to
be some of these traditions to become
hard to hold on to and I'm not not
nostalgic about wanting to keep them or
protect them I just want to record them
because I think they will go away so
that excites me I'm working on another
book and that's personally something I
love to do for joy this that's the only
reason just because I'd love to record
and document these things and see them
but the other thing I'm excited about in
the kind of world of the future is AI I
can't
under I can't overestimate or over
enthuse on the disruptive nature that I
think AI will be in the broadest sense
and many people use analogies and I have
several analogies but the one that maybe
would make sense to most people was the
Industrial Revolution was this huge huge
thing from the world of agriculture
where we used our own physical
muscles and the muscles of animals to
get things done and then we had this
thing where we automated that with
artificial power artificial you know
electric power and steam power and later
gasoline power this is this is
artificial animal power artificial human
power that we used to to make our lives
so much easier and so much different I
mean everything our whole lives are
really the fact that this house has been
built using this automated power may
imagine if you had to make it by hand or
just is this insane we couldn't do it so
so behind this
so all these motors and and the
harnessing of that power propelled this
industrial revolution in the modern
world that we have well you know the 150
years ago farmers would take a item like
a hand pump and say we'll make it
electric
so they took things and they electrified
them what we're doing now at the very
beginning of it is we're gonna take all
the things that we electrified and we're
not gonna cognate eigth em we're gonna
add intelligence to them everything and
not just things that that electric but
even inert things like a chair like the
door people laughs and they say whoa and
put a computer in the door 20 years ago
or 30 years ago yes go to a hotel today
there's a computer in your door there's
a little card reader so we're gonna just
keep adding this and this gonna get
smarter and smarter in multiple
different ways and so that intelligence
I call artificial smartness it's not
like human intelligence
it's like artificial powers like
synthetic learning it's just very
specific narrow brute-force kind of
intelligence and so wow we could think
of our lives as having like when you
drive a car it's what 240 horsepower you
have 240 horses at your disposal and if
we were do the same thing with AI like
you're gonna have like 250 minds right
here to do whatever it is that you want
to think about or solve you just hire
this and so it'll be like electricity in
a sense that you're not gonna make the
AI you're gonna buy it
Nabeel Amazon Web Services exactly
exactly
in fact Google is now selling their AI
you can purchase AI from Google today
and that's what we'll do
yes give sixty to sixty cents sixty
cents per thousand instances really yes
and Google I can do amazing things like
it can look at a picture and tell you
what's going on in a picture and you can
actually ask the questions you can say
is there what's that person wearing what
color is that is that hat what are they
doing with it and it'll tell you back
sixty cents a thousand what would your
response be to those who have fear of
the rise of the machines
yeah Skynet and creating the summoning
of demons that we can't control
etc yeah yeah um how would you respond
to that or comment on it I would say
first of all it's possible but very
unlikely why do you say that a lot of a
lot of reasons one is is that the
general trend is is that automation
including this AI will create more jobs
than it destroyed and will take a lot of
jobs away I think in 20 years at least
50% of the people driving trucks we're
no longer drive trucks and by the way
truck driving is the most common
occupation in the US did not know that
yeah so 50% of those won't have jobs the
pretty long haul trucks and stuff like
that so there will be jobs I like to
think there are tasks they're gonna be
taken away so automation including
white-collar tasks like you know
mortgage people working in bank halls
has all anything if you're if you're if
you have a job that's defined by
productivity or efficiency that's a job
is going to go to the AI that's a so
productivity is for robots okay yeah per
TVs for robots what humans are going to
be really good at are asking questions
being
and experiences so that's almost
everything in our world right now is
becoming cheaper and cheaper and cost
the few things that are increasing costs
are all experience based tickets to a
concert tickets to Hamilton tickets to
travel personal coaching a nursing care
you know weddings all the those are the
things that are going up in price
because they're all they're not
commodify herbal they're not
manufacturable they're there they are
experience based they're not efficient
science is terribly inefficient you're
not learning anything less you're making
mistakes that's inefficient by
definition innovation is inherently
inefficient so we will move to those
things and they all have to be highbrow
again you know nursing care being
companion for someone giving them
attention giving them an experience so
there's there's a big room there but I
think we're gonna move away from things
that could be measured in terms of
efficiency is anything that's concerned
with efficiency whether it's
white-collar knowledge work or physical
work goes to the robots what has been
the most impressive VR experience or
profound that you've had yeah so this is
a good question because I saw them all
and I saw this the secret of magic leap
which had a really good visual
representation but it turns out
magically being augmented reality it was
it was a they caught a mixed reality
because it's the kind where you have a
clear glass that you're wearing like
Google glass but you have a full vision
and there is a synthetic or an
artificial object or a being or
something in in your vision so we could
be looking around this room now have
these glasses on and I could see either
a virtual screen or a virtual teacup or
a virtual book or a virtual animal yeah
and it would look it would be really
present you know there's a this for
people who want to just get a sample of
this I'm sure you just google it but
there's also really I thought a good
piece written by Chris Dixon on what's
coming next in computing I think was the
title
line and there's a little animated gif
of magic right
a demonstration of this little sort of
fun right looks like a japanimation kind
of robot right getting out under
someone's desk right and it's very vivid
and I saw the robot and so there are
several things about the the word
doesn't work where they have to improve
is that that object is not lit in the
same way as the rest of the room so
there's a little mismatch to do that to
light that thing and render it in real
time with the light of the room is we're
way off on that so what you have is you
have an artificial thing is really there
it's like having a cartoon thing you
know it's not really real but you really
is there it's like Who Framed Roger
Rabbit yes so but that's very useful
like if you're making if you're
designing your prototype and you can
actually walk around you can have
virtual screens so they talk about this
being the last screen because within it
if you wear this with goggle you can
have virtual screens that are very very
highly detailed like I could watch HD
movie in it without any discomfort at
all so you can have as many screens as
you want and you're interacting with
them but there's you just take off the
goggles and they're gone which means you
can also make them appear anywhere you
want so this is the future of work and
you can actually have teleconferencing
which is another thing where you have a
virtual person next to you and that is
amazing it's something I would pay like
I don't know thousands of dollars for
right now if I could have that so you
were you in general then does that mean
more impressed by the augmented reality
or mixed reality than virtual reality
augmented or mixed reality is the more
difficult of the two to do and if you
can do mixed reality you can do VR just
by turning the lights down making it
black
so technically VR is a subset of the
mixed reality understood okay so so the
visual accomplishment of like magic leap
is there but here's that wasn't the most
amazing experience I had it turns out
that the visual is only 50% of your
sense of experience
the tactile is the audio and the feeling
and using your hands and your body and
the best experience I had that was
really amazing was something called the
void based in Utah and they are making
an arcade version of VR where you they
provide all the equipment and you go and
you pay for an experience say for half
an hour you pay $30 for 30 minutes and
you go in and they're gonna give you
it's a full vest you're suited up and
it's amazing it really is because they
mix the real and the virtual and so let
me give you a kind of an example there's
something called redirected walking the
way redirector walking is is imagine you
have your goggle on you see as you see
something inside and you turn 90 degrees
hard a 9 degree turn to the right but
what you'll see is only an 80 degree
shift they're cheating you ten degrees
and they can compound that cheat so that
you think you're walking in a straight
line for a mile across this amazing city
that they have you go sir Clerk going in
a circle
that's and you don't know that and they
could do redirected touching where
you're grabbing things and you think
you're going different think it was the
same thing or even stairs that are that
are thinking you think you're walking up
the stairs but it's the stairs that are
kind of cycling through attaining right
and so they're able to give you a 30
minute where you're exploring this
incredible thing and you're just a
little tiny room Wow
okay and here's the other cool thing
they did in this experiment a peak vest
that's vibrating and doing all kinds of
stuff and they had you got this elevator
you're kind of a second-story and
there's this we still have an Indiana
Jones demo that I saw and there's this
floor right before you and it's kind of
like the it's rocky and it's like not
very stable and you need to get across
and you're walking across and you fall
down two storeys
and what happens is that you're on a
platform that moves six inches but you
have just fell two stories okay wow that
sounds terrifying
well no it's exhilarating the poor just
like drop out from under you like
cartoon style and they're like waiting
for a second exactly the point of all
this they have great wavers the point of
all this because there's only moves is
six inches
point of all this is that that there are
all these tricks to what we assign our
own believability of what is real where
we are and just like cinema exploits a
trick of our vision yeah you think
Mickey Mouse which is not a real
character it's throwing a baseball and
you said that ball is really moving
across the screen but there's no
movement right there's only a series of
still images that week assemble in our
brain and VR is exploiting a similar set
of new discoveries to so our bodies
believe that these things are happening
our minds know well it's like going from
optical illusions to full-body sensory
exactly and this turns out to be very
very important and so what I say is and
what I discovered from looking at this
VR is that we're moving from an Internet
of information where you can get any
information anywhere in the world
anybody who lives anywhere it could have
all the information they want to an
Internet of experiences and this is very
very powerful experiences and so it's
not just experience of you know horror
or following but all kinds of other
experiences that we're gonna have in and
when you're there you come out of these
VR and it's not that you remember seeing
something you remember something
happening to you it's a much it's a much
different present fact first-person
shooter games turn out to be a little
too emotionally exhausting when you're
in VR produce PTSD if it gets really
it's yeah I mean when there was this
there was there was this VR documentary
of going to a pig slaughter and you're
in the chute with pigs
and it's just like you they said people
said I could watch that but I can't like
go through it go through it can't be in
the air and there was another demo
someone had what's called killing the
alien we were trying you have to stab
this alien being and the alien being a
minute but it's it's like there's haptic
involved and stuff and people would mean
by haptic haptic is this term for
tactile of gas touch they call it haptic
technology and it means that that when
you grab something there's a response to
it or you there's reveal instance or
texture the texture and this is the
there's a lot of work and how do you get
that sense that you've grabbed something
or you can feel something how far do you
think we are from VR sex well let me
tell you ice well there's telling the
telethon teledildonics right are you
gonna remember I I saw I saw these guys
who have a technology for the with
called volumetric capture 3d volumetric
capture which means that getting all
sorts of terrible the images environment
to capture is a they use like seven or
more cameras to record a person in all
their detail so that when you see them
in VR it's not they're moving around and
you can see every single hair and you
can sell the I've ever did involve a
trick to the captured before but and
it's alive or just as a snack Jesus
still that's that's a difference yeah
this is not as still no understood but
even the still was URI I mean because it
was exactly me
right it was just mapped with you if you
zoomed in you could see these tiny
little grids and it right okay so the
volumetric capital of live of a live
movement is is amazingly because that
per in your new 3d presentation of it I
felt I mean I felt uncomfortable even
getting close to that person like you're
in their space you just you react to
they really feel it they're there and if
they are giving you eye contact and a
voice you you
have a total like again going back to
their body maybe your mind says they're
not really there but your body is saying
they are there that's them and it turns
out like the second life is now doing a
VR version called Sansa and it's a
thousand times better than the old
second life because those avatars are
being they're getting their body
language from that person they're
getting the voice and they have the eye
contact and even if their avatar is not
exactly them you could still see them
with their voice and their and their
body movements and the micro-expressions
it really is they're really there when
using the haptic technology we'll be at
a point where okay we've got two SEC's
yeah real pain in the ass Pleasant
reason just as well the reason I
mentioned that the volumetric captures I
was saying well this is amazing and
there and I was saying you know like sex
right and they were saying those are the
first people have come to us all the
porn oh yeah they've they were the first
that we you know we've got it we've got
to had that and I think I heard that
pornhub actually has a VR channel now or
something
Reisman right exactly it's the most
popular website in the world that no one
admits to going to right and I mean
they're been way ahead in terms of like
their use of video with video grammar
the summaries and stuff like that so I
haven't seen it personally but I I think
that to answer your question I'm sure
that right now there's probably one or
two places that have probably put this
together in a you know so would you say
if you had if you were a betting man if
you had to be right would you say
available to those who can afford it in
five years oh absolutely
less than five years absolutely less
than five years these you know as you
know the void is I think they're they're
already opened it's it's it's here to
outfit your whole body like this is it's
doable now I I think this is going to be
they're gonna be mostly regulated by
economics and then the law like where
where this is gonna get me and things
are gonna really just like a simulation
is just a I ran other actors like I'm
engaged Neil Stevenson let other people
who are their own haptic suits who
you're interacting with in which case
what types of laws apply right and whose
whose of your different states so yeah I
think this will be a very sticky problem
what are people worried about right now
that you think they shouldn't be worried
about oh this just been a the only
reason I asked you know what they
shouldn't be worried about well III
think the idea of the the AI sticking
over and killing us all cross that went
off I think they should be worried about
GMOs
I think cross that went off they should
not be worried it should not be worried
about GMOs we we generally modify all
the crops that you're eating we don't do
it we do them in different ways we do
them through breeding whatever it is but
they're all they're all been modified
and actually if you want to modify crops
modifying their genes with CRISPR is a
lot better than trying to modify them
with breeding because it's breeding you
have no control over what happens it is
a much more elegant process so CRISPR
you're not concerned about no there are
things I am concerned about in fact I
just saw a documentary last night which
will be released pretty soon it's called
zero days and it's the theme of it it's
very well done not sensational it looks
at this stuck necks virus which was a
computer virus that was invented
developed by the US and Israel to
demolish the the uranium processing
centrifuges in Iran so the the message
is they were looking at is can you
really destroy physical things with the
computer virus and answers yes you
absolutely can we're at the point where
you can actually affect the physical
infrastructure with
and then the question is what are the
rules for that and is that an act of war
like the Geneva Convention right and
they're in there turns out there is no
rules and yet the US and others are
developing these technologies and nobody
wants to talk about it because they're
all classified and therefore no one
wants submit to it therefore you can't
have the conversation about it and yet
Iran retaliated what they made they made
the largest cyber army in response to
that are the efforts to take them down
which did not work in the end and so
there already is cyber warfare going on
but it's not being talked about it's not
being emitted the US government won't
talk about the offensive and there's all
the other countries who are now building
capacity and what is the rules is is it
okay to disrupt the by you know the
banking system you know there's gonna be
collateral damage
what's accepted and I think that idea
that we don't have any rules for a cyber
war is something I'm really worried
about yeah
well that's I mean I remember at a
conference a few years ago this very
very well respected technologist got up
and talked about precisely this cyber
warfare and some of the scarier
scenarios and potential tactics that
could be used for instance if there were
a natural disaster in San Francisco and
people went to Google assuming that
there was still Internet connectivity to
try to determine how to respond
you know if someone could initiate the
disaster somehow and then also figure
out a way to present certain search
results that were misinformation you
mean that's maybe even more elaborate
than its necessary like maybe that's the
double-oh-seven bad guy like I'm gonna
leave you here with a sophisticated
laser set up while I go have a sandwich
Mr Bond I'll see you in 20 minutes and
it gets away maybe it's a lot simpler
than that right maybe it's taking out
electrical grids with different types of
viruses or electromagnetic pulse
weaponry or for that matter I mean I've
been astonished at how vulnerable
stuff is to just long-range marksmanship
for instance I mean there's like old
technology yeah I applied to an
increasingly fragile in some capacities
internet-of-things right exactly
so so and then there when you introduce
AI into that as the u.s. Pentagon has
just had some funding to have AI do this
kinds of stuff to weaponize AI basically
I'm also worried about that I you know
killed decisions this idea of we have
right now we have legally mandated
assassinations in the u.s. we we have we
have assassinated US citizens okay so I
could you elaborate on that with the
drones the drones got it the the drone
program will take out a particular
individual so we killed what's his name
the the he was an American citizen in
Yemen I guess and they targeted him in
the Kelton without there was no trial
there was nothing so we now have
assassination but these drones are
usually have people back in Nevada
steering them but there's and they
usually have generals and there's a
whole chain of command involved to do
the kill decision but increasingly
there's there's you know pressure to
expand this kind of warfare because you
prevent you don't have to have troops on
the ground the American public seem much
more sympathetic to sponsoring warfare
this and as that increases there's the
need to have autonomous so you don't you
know that's a very long feedback loop to
come back have humans decide and this or
that if you could have autonomous AI
driven drones that didn't need that then
they could actually be making these
decisions that's scary that's very scary
do you think just because this is also a
topic of common debate in Silicon Valley
in the AI circles so there are some
people who would say well if you look at
deep mind or some of these other
a I focused groups in the u.s. they have
ethics committees they are collaborating
with one another to look at safeguards
the real people you need to be worried
about are sort of the fast-moving solo
acts in places like China in places like
fill-in-the-blank who do not have that
kind of safety first mentality and
people would argue maybe that's not the
case in the u.s. either in certain
places but if someone's going to cause a
big mess with AI who do you think the
most what are the characteristics you
know AI is still so early in it that
that that I I don't have her I guess but
I do acknowledge and I would emphasize
that this is a global enterprise and the
Chinese are very keen on making AI in
the three ingredients you need for AI
these days is these deep neural Nets
like deep mine and then you need huge
farms of GPUs graphical processing units
which are been commoditized by the video
game interesting video chips yeah that's
it turns out there are parallel
processors that are really affordable so
before a I was done on supercomputer
parallels that would cost millions and
millions of dollars and then it turns
out that these little video chips that
you make for video games or parallel
processing and they were really cheap so
now they buy these big farms of these
cheap video game processors so you need
lots of those and then you need big data
B data sort of the rocket fuel and so
the companies like Baidu and Alibaba who
have big data or actually able to do
this kind of AI right now and I think
there's no so there's no there's no
there's no monopoly on AI right now and
China the Europe even Japan will all get
into this business and
anything I mean yeah I would expect just
given history that there'll be a
disaster it's it's um you know AI
disaster of some sort
I mean it's inevitable right I mean it's
not to say that a I shouldn't be pursued
it's just like anything else I mean
someone will abuse if you're gonna have
large-scale water projects right there's
gonna be some horrible flood that'll
kill a bunch of people and right or
fill-in-the-blank disaster right so we
have to be ready for that and not freak
out about it
which is what I think what that'll be
one of the tendencies will okay stop AI
research the more federal funding AI
those are that will that will also
happen to people will respond to that by
saying we have to stop AI what if you
had to again sort of play Nostradamus a
little bit what do you think the first
few big wins of AI will be where people
will really step back and go whoa so I
so yes it it's going to be the well two
things I think there will be these huge
shoes big wins but what's very curious
about this is that whenever these winds
happen as they have in a pass then
immediately we don't call it a ai ai is
only what we can't do what we hope to do
is call AI and once we do it was called
machine learning okay and so the first
big win will be like will be a
translation okay real so we'll have a
little device that we can wear in our
ear and I'll hear you speaking Chinese
in a whisper and to me English okay and
then that will have that and I don't
know five years or so but where I could
call yeah that's no that's not a I
that's just that's just you know that's
just they're just dumb computers doing
this stuff it's no longer AI people
don't think of syria's AI oh that's just
that's this machine learn is just Siri
driving the car that's no longer a is is
of course of course computers can drive
a car of course it can play chess is
once it happens it's like of course it's
just that's obviously not ai ai is sort
of always what we can't do and so there
will be these wins like like you know
perfect translation
um that will be very common in talking
to your these assistant bots that's the
other thing you know you'll have these
conversations with do this do that echo
sounds a lot like doodoo the
legalisation temeka right okay
is that a I do people think of it as a
no they don't that's not a yeah that's
just echo whatever it is and so I think
that conversation is the interfaced
mostly to AI for a very long time and
will get really good at that and I think
then people will ignore it I mean people
will become invisible to him and I think
most of the I would be invisible like
we're talking about Amazon Web Services
it's gonna be behind the scene it's
gonna be very particular I mean right
now your calculator smarter than you are
in the arithmetic doesn't freak you out
right you think right that's great
Google is better than you and recall and
so these we have these very specific
artificial smartness and that's where a
lot of this is is like most of the AI
we're gonna make is not like human
intelligence that's why we're making it
the whole point is to think different to
make things that think differently than
us the reason why we want these AI to
drive cars is because they aren't
driving like humans they aren't worried
about what they left a stove on or you
know having an argument with the garage
they are just driving better than we can
drive and that's so we want to make will
make a lot of stuff that does things
that are not I mean like when Google is
remembering all the web pages in the
world that's inhumane that's all right
that's inhuman it's not anything we
could do and and so a lot of this stuff
will be and once we see then the
machines doing it will say well
obviously we weren't the only ones who
could do that but now it's all in
retrospect right do you this is a total
left turn but do you journal do you uh
is that a practice that you have or not
really it's an occasional practice and
something that I do occasionally at
night late at night when do you do it or
late and I meaning what triggers it like
yeah I'm totally aggressions on which
the you know the journal yeah the it as
I haven't been able to determine the
trigger but sometimes I'll just be
seized of this kind of like I need to
sit down and just
Journal stuff and write stuff and doodle
and it's sort of I haven't been able to
detect a pattern but I have a book that
I use and just it's called late night
and it's I usually do it late at night
very late and I'm just kind of I don't
know I'm just kind of maybe there's a
buffer that gets filled or something
after startup disk almost full when I
get this into my journal
what's change in your life or behavioral
modification are you proudest of in the
last say year or recent memory and which
are you which habits or behaviors you
most re trying to change good question
I think I'm working on I think it was
like Mark Zuckerberg who had this kind
of like he was going to give a thank you
note like every day for 30 days or
something so this idea of consciously
really trying to express gratitude
mmm-hmm in a kind of a disciplined way
is something I've been we're going to
try to make it more of a habit how do
you express gratitude is that a phone
call is that a text message generally
has been in email
I'm not a phone person I'm not a voice I
don't like voicemail I don't like
talking on the phone I I came into my
into my professional life I was
basically noticed online in writing
short telegraphic email ish stuff so for
some reason email is my medium and I'm
most comfortable with email it's a
gratitude well on that on that note I
want to thank you for taking time to
have yet another jam session I always
have a blast and what's what are you up
to right now what would you like people
to check out where can they find you
yeah so I have this book that will be
released June 6 it's called the
inevitable published by Viking
it's uh I think a pretty good outline of
the technological trends for the next 20
or 30 years at the highest level things
that we can't ignore and that we really
should be embracing and I think if you
are interested in sort of what's coming
that you really find it very useful
because it's not really technical it's
it's at a high level and if you're
looking to where things will be in 20
years I think I have a pretty good map
of where that's going and where can I so
people could I'm sure by the time they
hear this grab it on Amazon right and
where else KK org yeah so kick it out or
give as a home as my homepage and where
I hang out and there would be links if
you want other languages or the audible
version the Kindle I think that all
should be listed there and I may even
have a calendar ish thing going and I'm
going to be showing what you're up to
engagements were never right and in July
I'm going to be doing a bunch of stuff
of basically appearing on gazillion
podcasts have that dedicated that for
the month of July which is why I like to
do mine early yes this is an exclusive I
am so delighted Tim that you that you
reached out and made the invitation to
be at your glorious home and I'm
thrilled to have you here and I hope
that hope that was useful to the to the
listeners out there because we did kind
of go all over the place
that's why they come they can they come
for the OCD plus the ADHD a dash of
hopefully definitely intelligence from
my guests and occasionally a glimmer of
something approaching semi intelligence
on my part but everybody check out KK
darg
it's full of all sorts of things that
I've recommended many many times over
the years including 1,000 true fans of
course and much much more than that the
quantified self everything can be found
somewhere at the hub that is KK town org
we're on social media if somebody wanted
to say hello it would be the best place
to say hello I do
look the triggers Twitter stream and I'm
Kevin - Kelly the number two I have
Facebook which I don't look at as much
but actually I do look at Google+ you do
I do because I find that the comments
and the conversational is very very
high-quality even though there's not
that many people those are there are
very active and I pay attention
so Kevin Kelly if they just searched
Kevin Kevin Kelly on Google+ perfect all
right and we will put that in the show
notes so everybody listening you can
find everything we've talked about is
assuming I can track it down in the show
notes at four hour work week dot-com
forward slash podcast you can also find
links to our previous conversations we
had two very very fun conversations
where we went into a lot of Kevin's bio
and asked a lot of my usual rapid-fire
questions we've already covered
previously and you can find that and
much much more at four hour work week on
four slash podcast and Kevin firstly
thank you very much also for taking the
time that I always have so much fun and
to everyone listening as always and
until next time thank you so much for
making the Tim Farriss show part of your
daily podcast experience hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday that provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I
you enjoy it this episode is brought to
you by 99designs when your business
needs a logo website business cart
thumbnail or any other design I
recommend checking out 99 designs I use
them myself I've used them for many
years I use them to create book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to becoming number one York
Times best seller have also used them
for banner ads illustrations and much
more with 99 designs you get a variety
of original designs from designers
around the world give your feedback and
then pick your favorite your happiness
is guaranteed so check out some of my
competitions and designs and some of
your competitions and designs from
fellow Tim Ferriss show listeners at 99
designs com forward slash Tim and right
now you can get a free $99 upgrade on
your first design so check it out 99
designs com forward slash Tim this
episode is brought to you by headspace
more than 80% of the people I have
interviewed world-class performers
across the military entertainment sports
and beyond all have some type of
meditative practice I tried for years
and years and failed miserably the key
is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than 4 million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is rooted in thousands of years of
traditions supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder and II put it Combs TED talk
which has more than 5.5 million views
his last name is PUD VI c om ve if you
want to look that up but otherwise
download the free headspace app I have
it on my phone and begin there take ten
program for ten days of guided
meditation completely free ten minutes a
day that's all it takes you should give
it a shot
headspace calm forward-slash Tim just go
to headspace calm forward-slash Tim
you